hi everyone we have a ray of sunshine at
the desk today you fell in love with her
on the good place Emmy nominated I might
add the irresistibly and charmingly
funny Janet it is walking and talking
human Delight Darcy Cardiff
I need extra caffeine is that what it is
yes I'm so excited for your new movie
shotgun wedding Josh Duhamel came here
and he was so fun he's amazing are you
so good in this movie oh my gosh well
there's so many stars in this movie
hello J.Lo hello also
you know you see him right there look
Cheech Marin right there Cheech Marin
I know oh so um okay you guys had some
fun you were all like hanging out while
you shot did you have the kind of fun
that I would imagine you would have with
cheats I mean he um he he has fun but
he's he's just great have either of you
met him he's amazing really briefly I
met him yeah yeah he's so nice he's so
smart and cool and he's been in one
trillion movies like you think of him as
Cheech and Chong but he's been in so
many movies and he's so knowledgeable
and he's just like down to earth and
great and he even like made us tacos one
night and we hung out with Cheech well
it is time for Drew's news and we're
here Darcy would you hit
me okay here we go
first up the mirror reports a bride in
China just went viral for this sweet
move she invited all her ex-boyfriends
to the wedding and sat them at the same
table to make sure things were Crystal
Clear she added a sign that said table
of ex-boyfriends
I love this yeah I do I don't know if I
would do it but I love it I thought you
know I thought about this a lot and your
wedding day's day you probably are going
to look the best you're ever going to
look in your entire life so so yeah I
think you should invite all your exes
and walk through like Julia Roberts
dad
[Applause]
that's what the article said was that
she wanted them to know what they missed
out exactly yeah would you ever do that
yeah would you do that yeah I didn't he
didn't we kept it real strictly friends
and fam no ex-lovers I don't think I was
gonna say okay maybe you're inviting
people from your entire life isn't there
someone you made a bad decision or you
know a one night weird like one-off with
things happen you know what I mean
things are crazy I'm looking out at the
audience of my wedding in my mind right
now there's not one single one that I
you know what with no
nothing nothing I know I'm trying to
think too hmm
no ah that would be a twist with that
yeah I don't know people oh okay I was
just kidding
well that's the one and only Martha
Stewart turned 81 last year and how does
this
wow today so young and hot Yahoo life
reports that Martha rides horses she
does Pilates she hits the gym but she
also has her friends in her age group
hold her accountable she says quote if
we start to act like little old ladies
and don't care what our house looks like
or how it smells or anything we get
killed well Martha is Hardcore and Darcy
you met some amazing 90-somethings
working on A League of Their Own I did
which I absolutely loved you know Abby
was here
I love Abby she loves you well and you
guys are so good in that show together
so much I mean just amazing did you guys
meet any women with wisdom we did we did
we got to work with um in particular
Mabel Blair who was in the original
League yeah I think you we
[Applause]
made out
amazing and she's full of advice and
she's full of like little wisdomy
factoids and she I think her like whole
deal is like Life's a party I think she
has said that she lives that like we're
here for a short time in her case a long
time but it's just like be here and have
fun and like live in the moment she's
just I I
I love her I love her so special I never
got to talk to her about it too yeah she
was on set a lot it was great that's
great it was great yeah okay I want to
know what you think about this a British
vote says the newest trend is eating
alone yeah going out to a restaurant
eating alone some some people's worst
nightmare but they say there's no shame
in the party of one game they say the
stigma is gone and 2023 is the year
and eat by yourself I love that if they
go further through they say while you're
at it to ditch your phone ditch your
copy of Anna Karenina you're pretending
to read and just and just focus be in
the present right be there with your
meal and do it you are an eat alone or
Drew major Eat Alone yeah
I do too you do it as well you're fine
with it I am fine with it I I think I
probably am a little too reliant on my
um bone in my Anna Karenina yeah but oh
I would love to be reading well I like
to do a crossword puzzle I always bring
my crossword puzzle with my erasable pen
oh cute and because I can't see the
pencil anymore because I'm too old and
so I've got my erasable ink pen and I
just sit there and I stimulate my brain
yeah and it's it's just if I don't have
some type of reading material I do feel
naked and vulnerable yeah yeah yeah I
get that but I like to go and I have I I
I'm eating alone but I'm eating for two
right so I order like pregnant no no I'm
just hungry I always get like a martini
I get an appetizer and I'll fall entree
and then I just love to look at the
restaurant and see people pick up on
story lines and judge people
yeah I feel confident like alone with no
distractions or devices or I I I think I
am starting to feel more and more
confident alone but I I love when I'm
when I have dinner with my husband he I
like to do what you do I like to like
eavesdrop on people and he doesn't he's
always like come on come on we're here
exactly last night we were at dinner and
on one side of us was like a table of
four women that I could tell they were
like old friends that had sort of maybe
didn't have as much in common anymore
and I could tell they all like hated
each other and I just wanted to like
listen yeah and then on the other side
there was a couple who I could tell was
on their first date but I think they had
slept together before
great I just want I was like Jason you
go home let me just let me just sit here
and eat my Sushi and listen Okay Darcy
you know what the next time I I go eat
alone I'm gonna do a little
eavesdropping in your honor yeah that's
your legacy if I leave nothing else I
cannot thank you enough for coming here
we absolutely love you shotgun wedding
is streaming now on Prime video
[Applause]
[Music]